that makes me think about uh food that
sounds disgusting but actually delicious
that sounds disgusting food s wrote this
down but it says food that sounds
disgusting but actually delicious
um see there's two ways we can go about
it the name sounds disgusting but it's
actually good or the concept sounds I
think should be the concept that sounds
disgusting if you say [__] shirako
I'm I'm leaving Joey that that sounds
disgusting and it is disgusting no
that's all sounds disgusting and is
disgusting oh that's delicious as well I
will not take [__] I'm going nut for
slander from you two non-japanese people
uh there's a lot of Japanese foods that
are like that like I'm just thinking
most Japanese food I okay okay okay one
for me that I I actually saw by like
real life example was when I first uh
brought a couple of my like Australian
high school friends to Japan right and
they were the kind of like super like
Western friends who like never tried you
know proper like Japanese food or like
any kind of Asian food and I took them
to eat skiaki okay right and they
thought the concept of the raw egg was
discovered
Jackie is like a like a meaty broth
where you cook all the veg like a hot
pot but so you cooked all the veg and
the meat in the top part but the what
makes it unique is that you have a raw
egg on the side that you whisk kind of
to make it all uh like consistent yeah
then you dunk everything in this broth
in the raw egg then eat it yeah it's
really good yeah but it sounds kind of
gross yeah you know you don't cook the
egg before you cook the meat and then
dunk the cooked meat in the raw egg Yeah
so basically the meat and the vegetables
are like kind of sounds gross yeah yeah
it's been simmering in this like so soy
sauce base broth and now there's just
like a whole bunch of raw egg over it it
sounds gross if you've never had it but
when you have it you realize it's one of
the best types of hot pots you can have
in Japan it is delicious I don't know
the the yolk it just it's a natural
sauce yeah right and what what are you
gonna say yeah sorry I just had a bad
thought come on
I'm just gonna say the yolk just makes
such a delicious natural sauce that we
just have never had before yeah but when
I think about it it's like okay I think
to a lot of people conceptually that's
quite gross yeah yeah even though it's
pretty just pretty delicious uh so I
propose yeah the toast sandwich
it's just nothing it's just it's pretty
good that's like saying I like the taste
of it
get the [__] out of here corner okay
what are you talking about that is the
whitest thing you've said on this
podcast I can't had it I thought it
sounded dumb as [__] and I had it and I
thought it's not that bad it's pretty
good okay so explain so it's basically
is it a sandwich that has toast in it
it's yes it's two pieces of bread yeah
non-toasted bread and then you have a
toasted bread in the middle that you
normally season with salt and pepper and
then you put it just like in the middle
and you eat it it's pretty good you can
put butter on if you want to it's pretty
good it sounds gross but I would rather
just have [__] toast you know why why
am I feeling it
why am I filling myself up with two
extra slices of non-toasted bread when I
could also it's different it's good
you should try it we should all try it
what what compelled you to make this
thing well because I I I'd seen it so
many times and I thought well [__] it
I'll just try it like I just I before I
make my opinions on it yes it sounds
[__] stupid I did to be fair when we
were pretty good we were in the UK last
year I did go to like a bakery and I did
see it on their menu and I was really
short on the menu I've never seen it
I've seen I've seen it on the menu [__]
and it was like I never seen it on a map
I saw it on a menu and I was like that
can't be right I'm misreading this
British Cuisine let's put bread between
us
I'm going to use this to slant my taste
buds but hey it's not bad you've got to
try it before you you deny it I didn't I
didn't look solid enough as it is Connor
why didn't you tell me salt bread carbs
and just black pepper is just all I need
like that's good enough for me I'm like
a I'm like a I'm like a you know like
dogs and you give them dog to treat
every single day give them the exact
same [__] thing yeah how do you how
do they get so excited every time right
that's what I want for my food
well that's also because their brains
are smaller is that why yes if they had
bigger brains
again yeah so they're just less
incapable of being like um actually I've
had this for 200 days straight faster uh
I require some other type of sustenance
they don't have that knowledge
I'm slandering the bread sandwich but
you know what Crystal sandwich toast
sandwich crisp sandwich I actually get
behind that I like Christmas time just I
don't know does it sound disgusting
though is it it's just like socially
looked downable and I don't know why
because peasant food it's seen as a
peasant food and I don't know why it
should be seen as a delicacy [__] if
they say Yeah
dance securing his British citizenship
for Life
they're never they're never that like
they'd never be in question you know why
kids on a playground getting bullied for
bringing a crisp sandwich to school
let's not pretend that it's not like the
best meal we could have as a kid that
you it's the meal that you wanted as a
kid but you couldn't tell your parents
foreign
like chip sandwiches
yes I love chip sandwiches
fries yeah like hot chips I love those
love those pretty good I could I could
possibly uh that was that was like that
was my diet maybe some mail or something
too for us in Australia we've got some
chicken salt on that [__] okay another
thing that definitely sounds disgusting
and isn't that bad I'd say is well maybe
not delicious you'd probably agree I
think you'd say horses oh horse meat
horse sounds disgusting yeah
I don't think it's that it sounds
disgusting I think it sounds it's just
morally wrong yeah that's a lot of
people right it's like eating like cat
or dog yeah right it's like it's it's
not about like
I wouldn't say it's on that level but an
animal that we have let's say
domesticated and have put to use but
with domesticated horses no no exactly
yeah but like horses haven't been
domesticated on as wide of a like level
as not not white as well it's not as
wide spread as people owning cats and
dogs used to be pretty widespread oh he
used to be widespread I have no doubt I
don't think they did they eat it back
then I have no idea I'm not maybe maybe
in Japan they did yeah probably Japan
they've always been eating there yeah
and it's like doesn't move we need it I
had a there's this
um the seal sound disgusting it's seal
I'd seal in a can that just sounds oh I
I think I have as well it's just they're
very blubbery right yeah and like very
fatty it's like uh bear made as well it
wasn't very good yeah like does bear
meat sound disgusting yeah
you sound disgusting
apex predator I just feel is just
doesn't taste just shouldn't taste good
like crocodile
crocodile I've never had crocodile
before I've had crocodile it's like it's
like tough chicken
it is it's like tough chicken it close
your eyes does that sound disgusting yes
and I think they are disgusting I
actually from the [__] delicious holy
[__] frog legs I can't actually they
just like they just like they're just
like baby chicken legs I can't eat it
without picturing that frog dancing
I had it when I was in France oh okay
yeah yeah I did too and it came on a
plane I was like oh [__] it's that point
I just said I just imagine it happy
singing and dancing like 20 minutes ago
I don't know why what's wrong with my
brain oh yes okay frogs no but horses
yeah I'll [__] eat yeah
I'm not a horse person so I don't care
about are you a frog person kind of like
frogs
frogs are cute as [__] it's not cute
okay what about escargot I was going to
say now that we're on the escargon you
know I guess Gaga I'm not a fan I quite
like it why does God look so stunned by
me saying that
I was just no I wasn't stunned I was
like why why am I not surprised that
Joey's like yeah it was delicious it's
great she already likes everything weird
depends on my mood because sometimes I
you know we don't we don't want to admit
it but our mental image of something uh
can affect the texture you know it's
it's if you associate a food or a drink
it's like a bad time or a bad experience
it also is worse as well yeah yeah
exactly like I've had escargot and I I'm
fine with the taste I I'm never going to
like go out and look for it uh but I'm
I'm not like opposed to it but when I
know it's escargot I I know that there's
this part of my brain that is just like
you're eating a [__] slimy ass snake
is it is it a weird okay in that in that
vein isn't it also weird that we're
totally okay with eating snails but
we're not okay with eating slugs
well I mean okay I've always thought I'm
not okay with it either of them okay
yeah I'm not okay why did you assume we
are okay with eating slugs like as in
like we're okay with eating snails but
we're not okay with eating I always
found the snails
again snails with a more refined slugs I
always thought they were the classier
slugs you know they're just the Slugs
that live in Caravans all right yeah
yeah it's like the broke the broke snail
is the slide right like it's like you
know like snails are like snails you
know looks uh slugs are just like snails
that have gone through like the homeless
the homeless crisis you know
they ain't Rich enough to buy a home
they're obviously
I I had one [__] I had it I forgot it um
it was
um what
like I forgot it okay what kind of
things is there any animal body part to
you that sounds disgusting uh testicles
testicles yeah I've had I've had I've
had like balls testicles before
um conceptually I was like all right I'm
eating nuts um yeah you know that's
whatever but but I'm very much in the
mindset of like you know whatever it
might be conceptually as long as it
tastes good yeah I'm okay with it for
the most for me I'd actually because I I
think I'd actually rather eat a testicle
um than even out of contact yeah yeah
I'd rather eat a testicle like
conceptually right yeah I know something
about eating like a blood vessel or a
blood vessel so like like like like a
vein or something like oh a vein because
I've seen that before I can eat veins
yeah uh it's like a blunt like a vein on
artery or something right
it's I I've seen that before and I'm
just like how do they get it out intact
what do you mean like like usually it's
like quite you know they're quite small
right so do they just pull up well some
of like the main big arteries oh I see I
see I like you know it's pretty pretty
[__] fat something about something
about something about that just like
freaks me the [__] out and I'm like
eating God yeah okay something that
sounds conceptually disgusting yeah fish
eggs
fish eggs look and sound disgusting when
you before you've had them and then you
try it you're like oh they're quite
refreshing sure yeah if you'd never had
fish eggs like and you've no you don't
have a culture of eating them and
someone had said hey can you do you want
to eat fish eggs like my parents were
like I told them that and they were like
oh like is that like caviar I'm like
yeah yeah it's caviar but different well
caviar is fish eggs yeah well it's like
it's in like the oh like salmon the
normal common fish eggs that you eating
yeah fish eggs are [__] delicious
yeah
um I remember some like because uh
whenever like in Thailand uh whenever
there's like you know if you fry the
fish sometimes the fish eggs sometimes
they don't remove the fish eggs from the
fish
yeah so so you opened it up and it's
just like packed full it's just it's
just like walking out huh oh that's good
it's delicious and it's one of the most
delicious parts of the fish I think
because it's fried it absorbs all of the
sauces that you fried in I think they're
both separate now I'm realizing I like
them with their I don't see the eggs
from the fish I like that I just see the
eggs but that's weird though
conceptually it's no different right
it's just it's just separated yeah yeah
that's like being like Oh I like
sausages and I like mashed potatoes but
I don't like bangers and mash it's the
equivalent to that I think it's just
seeing you know sometimes everyone
always says like how the sausage is made
yeah yeah it's like I I see how the
sausages made and I don't mind that I'm
like that's that's fine but when I see
where the eggs come from like oh yeah oh
that's weird yeah like when I see those
videos where they open up the sturgeon
to get the caviar yeah and they just
[__] rip this thing's stomach open
like a doom like video and then grab all
these hundreds of thousands of eggs
you're just watching a C-section man
yeah that's basically what you want but
it comes in the tin I don't question it
and I'm like that's nice yeah that's
cool but it's all about packaging but
when it when it comes directly they've
ripped it out I'm like whoa that's a lot
yeah I think caviar is like overrated
anyway I don't like caviar yeah I was
like this is [__] it's pretty overrated
it's it's the same as any other
ingredient you can't just slap it onto
anything and just hope they taste good
because people just [__] add it to
the menu to to make it more expensive
yeah I know I don't think anyone
actually cares about the flavor yeah
because it's just salt it is it's just
it's just a little salt and uh it's it's
a little bit of salt and a little bit of
like sea and like fishy fish yeah sea
water flavor sea salt yeah it's just
very
very expensive let's be honest all right
that's what it is oh my God that can
taste good but uh definitely not worth
the price uh that you picked I think I
was a weird kid I think I remember I
liked the taste of the sea salt like the
the sea like I think I got it on me and
I liked like my I had like a wristband
on or something I licked it I don't know
why I don't know I'm licking everything
I think I licked it I was like damn this
[__] tastes good I know it does taste
whatever it is
why the cholera tastes so good in the
ocean have you have you never gone like
swimming then it dries out and then your
Skin's like all like flaky because of
the salt yeah like oh that tastes good
like when you actually get it in your
mouth and you're like you're like I'm
not gonna tell anyone this but it tastes
really [__] good I tastes good
because there's no other undoubtedly
amount of sewage in this and I'm not
gonna say that yeah yeah because because
like I remember when I was a kid in
Thailand we had like we owned like a
bunch of dogs at our house and my
grandma did every time we'd go to our
trip to the seaside we'd come back and
the dogs would just like [__] repet
them we'd Pat the dogs on the dogs would
like lick the [__] out of my hands
I know